I am 50 years old and do you know what I don't want to do on my vacations anymore? Oh probably a few things. I don't want to cram my family into the same one bedroom room and bathroom. I don't want to. No. I don't want us all on top of each other. I want my own bedroom separate from the children, which is why I prefer Airbnb. Because we can all have our space, and then it's like, makes the whole vacation more relaxing. We can go to bed at different times. You know, I can stay up and read,
or more likely these days, I go to bed before everybody else. You know what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have what I love about Airbnb? What? Snacks. You have a fridge, you have a kitchen. So I'm not calling up room service constantly and having to pay that fee.
I'm just like, hey, we pack snacks, they're in the fridge, go get them. Well, everyone, consider Airbnb for your next adventure. You won't regret making the switch from a traditional hotel. Get groceries delivered across the GTA from real Canadian superstore with PC Express. Shop online for super prices and super savings. Try it today and get up to $75 in PC optimum points.
Visit superstore.ca to get started. Hello. Hi there. Hi, welcome to our second drink of Halloween. So guess what, Jenna? According to pretty much every online poll, in fact, I didn't find one where this wasn't true, season two Halloween is ranked
as the number one office Halloween episode. I don't doubt it. I think it's my favorite. I loved our breakdown of this episode because we had Creed in the studio for the entire episode and he shared so many fun things. Well, Ange, I agree and I actually panicked because I couldn't think of anything
that we hadn't already shared about this episode. You guys, Angela and I have been dividing up, taking the lead on second drinks and I was assigned to Halloween and I did not know what we were gonna do. I really felt like we shared it all. But then guess what? What? I found my old MySpace blog for this episode. Old tech. Yes and there were several tidbits that we never shared. Are you ready? I'm so ready. Alright first off, Ange, in our breakdown we talked about
your cat costume and how your tail was very hard to sit in. But according to my blog, one of the ears on your costume kept falling down and it was ruining takes. Do you remember this? I do remember this because sometimes I could feel it fall and it'd be flat on my head. And other times I couldn't. And so I would start talking and Oscar would be like,
your ear, you're gone. I'm like, what? But I had completely forgot about that till you reminded me and I was like, oh yes, it was driving us crazy. Well, I also shared that you broke several cookies in that scene that we had together in the conference room. You know the one where you ask me what I brought and I say brownies and you're
like really pissed off because you're like same category as you brought cookies? And then I like slam the tray down. Yes! In my blog I wrote this quote Angela kept slamming them down on the plate in disgust during the scene. I actually remember us breaking. I remember laughing because I broke them and I it's got to live somewhere in some blooper land. It must. I mean we talked about how that was a hard scene to get through but I failed to mention that you were destroying cookies with one ear. Now this episode also features the very first Jim and Pam air high five.
Mm hmm. I know we talked about it because I love it. Yes, we discussed it, but we did not talk about how that was an improvisation. That was not scripted, lady. So wait, it wasn't in the shooting draft? No, I can't believe I didn't share this the first time. In fact, there wasn't any description in the script for how Pam reacts to Jim pretending
to be Michael Scott on the phone. He does this impression of Michael, because they're tricking Dwight, and when he hangs up, we do the air high five. But in the script, it says nothing. It doesn't even say Pam looks delighted. And my memory is that John suggested that we air high five to give it a little button at the end. We nailed
it the first time and everyone freaked out on how cute it was. It was super cute. It's also the no look. The no look air high five. It's special. It's like, oh these two are in sync. What's gonna happen with these characters? Well this is where it all began. I love it. And then, Angela, according to my MySpace blog about this episode, Paul Lieberstein improvised a line in his scene with Steve that made Steve break. And I wrote that it took Steve two full minutes to recover.
And I'm like, wow, how did we not talk about this? I checked our breakdown and sure enough we had not discussed it. I went back, I watched the episode. There are not any scenes between Toby and Michael. It's a deleted scene. I must have written this MySpace blog before I knew what the episode was actually gonna be when it aired. Right, right. So there's this deleted scene where Toby asks Michael for the name of the employee that is gonna be fired so that he can start the HR paperwork.
And Michael tries to fire Toby. I found it and I thought we should listen to it. Okay. Michael? What? Oh, what? Michael, do you have the name of the employee you're letting go I'd like to start working on our place Fine
If you are so anxious to see a head roll, it's you There you brought it on yourself too bad Can't say that. I'm sorry. It's a relief. I don't report to you, Michael. I report to the head of HR in New York. You asked for a name. I gave you a name. Now you're not doing your job. Why don't you just resign? I was just sent someone else. You need to have an HR representative. Just know that if I could have fired you, I would have. I know, Michael.
What line made him laugh? Well, that's the thing. I said that it was some improvisation that made Steve lose it. I was clearly sitting in the background at reception observing this whole thing be shot, but I checked the script and it's exactly a scripted. So I guess maybe the improv didn't make it in the cut, but I do know that if anyone could make Steve break, it was Paul. I feel like it's the moment just very resigned.
He says, I know, Michael. I don't know. That's my guess. Well, finally, Angela, I shared in my MySpace blog that Rain, John, and Brian held their first ever PlayStation 2 boxing contest during our downtime for this episode. But I guess the episode finished shooting before they could finish the tournament.
I noted that Rain and John were down to their final fighters. That just brings me right back. I know. Those guys, we'd be in a scene and they'd be like, okay, last take, last take. We gotta go. We gotta go. We're like, guys, are you doing in a scene and they'd be like, okay, last take, last take, we gotta go. We're like, guys, are you doing your boxing match or are we doing the scene? Pretty much.
Well, that's a really fun second drink, lady. Thank you, I was very excited. Well, everyone, we hope you like this breakdown of Halloween. Like Angela said, it's with our dear friend Creed Bratton. It's a really good one. Creed is so fun, You're gonna love it. All right, here it is. Enjoy.
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Re-Watch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're The Office, ladies. I love it. Creed is here. Creed is here. Creed is in the house. Yeah. This is so amazing. Creed's going to be with us for the whole episode, guys.
Okay, Creed, you are our first in-house visitor, right? I mean, we've had people call in, but you're our first in-house guest. I'm the first one. I might have a bathroom break or something. I won't be here for the whole thing, but I'll be in and out. We can provide you with a bathroom break.
Okay, good, that'd be good. We can take a bathroom break. I'm old, I'm old school. Well, I'm old, so that's part of it, you know. I need everybody to know that I've already tiered up twice since Creed has been here. You've said two touching, well, first of all, just seeing you almost burst into tears, but then you've said like five amazing things that have touched my heart already.
Well, as soon as I get together with you, it's just back and we're back on the set, you know, and it's all like, oh, I miss you girls. Creed lives down the street from me. I think everybody who knows me knows this. Don't give them my address, please. I won't. Creed's address is. His hidden key is, yes, we are neighbors and it's one of the joys of my life that we're neighbors. I love that you're right around the corner. I love that we have-
We see each other walking. We see each other walking. We see each other hiking around the street. We do. Hey! You were walking, was it your daughter's dog? Your son's dog. My son's little Yorkie, yeah.
Your little Yorkie and I hear, hey pumpkin! And I turn around and it's Creed. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. And I'm like, hey, you're a little Yorkie. We see each other in the street. We do. Hey. You were walking, was it your daughter's dog?
Your son's dog. My son's little Yorkie, yeah. Your little Yorkie, and I hear, hey pumpkin. And I turn around and it's Creed. And we've also maybe had some adult beverage and Red Solo Pups. We may have. We may have. And we like to do a little bit of what we call the sauce trail and walk around having
a glass of wine. And watching documentaries. Oh yeah. Creed loves anything where like animals go crazy, like planet Earth. Yes, all that stuff. I just love it. All right. Well, we are really excited to have you here.
We are discussing the Halloween episode. Yes. Right, right. Season two, episode five. This was written by Greg Daniels and directed by Paul Feig, and it is the first episode that Creed speaks. Well, I actually spoke in diversity day. In diversity day, I had lines with Phyllis.
Yes, I told her. And they paid me afterwards. Well, the first day, first day D, remember that girl we had the first day D? Yeah. The first season. She thought I was part of the cast at the time. So she came over, we had a little hands and she said,
now you and Phyllis just start talking. And Phyllis said, wait, I said, nevermind, it's okay. Nevermind. Phyllis was gonna out you. Phyllis just start talking. And Phyllis said, wait, I said, nevermind, it's okay. Nevermind. Phyllis was gonna out you. Phyllis was gonna out me. So I said, nevermind, it's fine. And so we started, and I started talking about, you know, sacrificing goats or something, you know,
trying to tell her what was on her head. Your improv was sacrificing goats. Yes, yes, yes. So you can hear me in the background. And then later, and they said, wait a minute, Creed's talking in the background. And I said, oh shoot, how did that happen? Yeah, how'd that happen Creed?
So they paid me on the side, but they didn't say, but we can't. I said, no, it's fine. It's fine. And then not off camera, then also was the voice for the ride. Yes, for the mining ride. For the mining ride, you know. You are so funny. I think they paid attention to that one.
Yeah, you were so funny as the voice of the mining ride. For the mining ride, you know? You were so funny. I think they paid attention to that one. Yeah, you were so funny as the voice of the mining ride. And Isabel was watching that episode with me and she said, Mom, I know that voice. I know that voice. And I was like, wait, you're... Oh my gosh. She was like, I think it's Creed. She? How concerning is she?
She is... I mean, I didn't catch it. And then I looked it up and I'm like, Isabel, we do know that voice. It's Creed. Yeah. But anyway, this is the first time where I actually had some serious lines. It was six and a half pages. I remember Kent Subornak threw the script down and said, okay, here it is. This is your moment. Wow.
And I had memorized it forwards and backwards. I had set a timer on a little recorder at a night subliminally at two and three in the morning, that would go off and play the lines while I was sleeping. I had it backwards and forwards, no joke. I had it backwards. I knew this was the Rubicon. This is the place that I was gonna get, because my intuition said this is it.
And then of course we walk in the office and Greg came in and said, by the way we've made changes of course to the lines and we've reversed them around and added some new stuff. You okay Steve? He goes, yeah, fine. I go, oh. Because they used to do that to us all the time. All the time. We would come in and you just get new pages and then shoot the scene five minutes later. Yeah, they would hand you the pages and sometimes we've talked about this, the pages would be hot because they just came... Right off the copier. Right off the copier. And we'd drop them some and go, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Now change your lines that you have learned and you've been having a tape recorder play at three in the morning to you. Do you remember the backdrop there right off of where my desk and Kate's desk was and it was the screen there. So you could walk, you could sneak around the back and get to the green room from behind it, you know, that That set up like that. I walked back like that after they told me this and put my hands up and said, okay, here it is.
And I said, I've come this far, I'm gonna do this. And once we started that with Steve, it was like into battle, you know? And there was some improvisation on that scene because I was paraphrasing my lines because I was desperate. Well, you knocked it out of the park, Creed. Yeah, yeah. on that scene because I was paraphrasing my lines because I was desperate. Well you knocked it out of the park, Creed.
Yeah, yeah. Well Creed, you started out as a musician. Yep. And a very long successful career as a musician. How did you even end up on the show in the first place as our stand in slash background person? Background person. I was working on Bernie Mac and Ken Quapus came on to direct an episode,
and they'd been using me for all these little vignettes and where I was doing funny. And if you ever watch old Bernie Mac, you'll see me all the time in the background mugging up. I really want to see that. I want to go back. I'm always in the background doing some stupid stuff, and they just allow me,
because I made Bernie laugh. I want to go back. I'm always in the background doing some stupid stuff, but they don't allow me because I made Bernie laugh. I made them laugh. And so Ken was talking about this guy's funny and he heard from Joe Moore, the first AD that I was in the grassroots. So he sent to Amoeba for some albums for me to sign because he was a big grassroots fan. And we started talking and talked about music and he's very knowledgeable. Then I found out that he was doing the Office of American Workplace and I was a big fan of the Ricky Gervais show.
He gave me his number. Now, I've never ever called anybody like that before. I called him as my intuition said, this feels right. This feels right. And Ken would not have given you his number. I feel like Ken is so discerning. Oh my God. If he didn't mean call me. Yeah, so he did. And so he talked to Greg and then I talked to Ken later and he said,
I talked to Greg, I told him you're a very interesting and funny guy. And he said, well, what we'll do, and this is his words, Greg's words, we'll put him in the background and see if we can work him in the mix. And that first time that was it, working in the mix. That's all I need to hear. That's why I took liberties just kind of like pretending that I was part of the group and that paid off, you know? Yes. Oh, I love that. Oh, that is so cool. That is awesome. What's next? Should we do a summary? Jenna, do you have one? You know I do. Yes. So in this episode, Halloween, Michael
is told that he must fire someone during the month of October due to cutbacks at Dunder Mifflin. But in true Michael fashion, he waits until the very last day of October, which also happens to be Halloween. He also has no idea who to fire. He has not made a decision. He spends the entire episode trying to figure out
what to do while the rest of us are dressed in our costumes for the Halloween party. I love that. I love that. I love the juxtaposition of that someone is gonna get fired while wearing a ridiculous costume. And they're gonna have to go home fired in that outfit. Well, I have a fast fact about this episode.
Fast fact number one, Greg Daniels wrote this episode and he told me that the inspiration for this episode was that he had always wanted to do a story about someone being fired, but from the point of view of the boss rather than the employee. He felt like we always see stories of people being fired and how they're wrestling with having been fired,
but he was like, you never see what it does to the boss. That's the genius of Greg Daniels right there. Absolutely. Well, the problem that this plot presented for Greg was that he was going to have to fire someone on the show. He was gonna have to pick a Dunder Mifflin employee to be part of the plot.
Well, he couldn't fire any of the series regular characters because we all had contracts, and he didn't wanna fire any of the series regular characters because we all had contracts and he didn't want to fire any of the supporting cast even though at this point you guys still did not have your full-time contracts, right? No, we didn't. We didn't become series regulars till booze crews. So listen, we were all on the chopping block. Were you a little worried? Well, maybe. Well, Greg didn't have any intention of losing them. He didn't want to lose anyone in the warehouse. But he also told me he didn't want to hire someone new that you'd never seen on the show just to fire them.
He felt like those stakes would feel very manufactured. So he turned to our two background actors, Creed and Devin. Creed and Devin, yeah. And he was like, well, these guys are very well established on the show at this point. And this is where I'd like to know what happened because I know the end of this story, which is that Greg found out that Devin had a theater contract coming up that he was going to go on on tour with a play. And so that- That's what Devin said.
Yeah. At the time though, they told us, one of you guys are gonna have to go. Oh man, geez. And we went, but we don't know yet. We're just gonna do that. We're gonna shoot you both. We're gonna see how it works out.
Oh my God. Wait, they're gonna shoot the scene two ways? They know that we're gonna shoot the thing because they could have gone back and changed it, I'm sure. Oh, oh, cause Michael could have said, you know what, I said it was Creed and it's Creed. You can't change my mind. But it was gonna be one of us.
They said it was gonna be one of us. And I remember being a little nervous. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. And Devin and I were friends. We'd become friends by this time. Well, sure. And by the way, you know, on the finale, jumping ahead a lot.
I don't know if I could kind of jump ahead. You can. You can. When Greg brought me to the office to find out what I wanted to do for the Kree character, I said, well, one thing I'd like to do is sing the song. Sing my song, but I also think we should have Devin back on the show. Oh, great. That's nice. We get together sometimes, you know, and have coffee and stuff like that.
I was feeling nervous because I was feeling bad that I might have to go, but also that Devin might have to go too. So it was mixed blessings and all that stuff. All right. Fast fact number two. This is the first time we see Pam's hair down instead of her usual half up half down hair clip. That to me is so important. Oh, well then Creed, you're going to love some of my note cards if that's important. Buckle in.
But this was a huge deal. Kim Ferry, our hairstylist and me and, and Paul Feig, we all had a meeting about Pam's hair and if we could let her hair down. And it was, I mean, it must have been 30 minutes we talked about it. There was a lot of concern that she might look too pretty with her hair down. And I can't remember how we got permission. Kim was delighted. I mean, Kim had been putting my hair in a hair clip now
for like 12 episodes or something. She was so thrilled to be able to scrunch it. Do something different. Anything, anything different. And it was kind of a big deal. So. Well, they were playing down both of your beauties all the time with the way they dressed you
and put you in scruff. That's right. Did everyone hear that? Did you fight? Oh, that's true. Creen says they played down's true. That's true. It says they played down our beauty. That is true.
Toward the end, did you guys lobby for, come on, just let us show a little bit of, you know. I remember really wanting lip gloss. I was- Yeah, something like that. So what's funny to me is that that was a 30 minute meeting about your hair. Meanwhile, I go to hair and makeup
and they put on full, enormous, purple, fake eyelashes on me. If you look at me as this cat, I have big purple eyelashes. They were so huge, I had a hard time even navigating them. When I watched the episode, I look a little sleepy. I think it's because I couldn't open my eyes. No meeting. No meeting. I was like, are you sure?
They just put them on me. And then one of the writers walked up to me, I can't remember who, and was like, are you sure? They just put them on me. And then one of the writers walked up to me, I can't remember who, and was like, do you have purple? It's probably Mindy. She was like, do you have purple lashes on? She might've been jealous. Yeah. Yeah, she wanted them.
She would want those purple lashes. No one said anything. Why is Angela Martin putting on purple fake eyelashes? Everyone was too busy meeting about my hair. Yeah. Yes, yes. All right, fast fact number three. Creed, too busy meeting about my hair. Yeah. Yes, yes. All right, fast fact number three. Creed, I don't know if you remember this, Angela, I think maybe you do.
The week we shot the Halloween episode, Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant visited one day. I know this because I have a photograph with them- In your cat outfit? In my cat outfit, and Jim is three hole punch Jim, but you can't really see the holes cause he's got his arm around someone. So it's a whole picture of our producers and Ricky and Steven and me and John. And I am the only person wearing a costume.
I like to imagine that they came to see me in a play where I played a cat or something. Your one act play? Cause we look like we're standing backstage. And you were in the cast, yeah. You're the only one in a costume. This is how I know this because I only have two pictures of myself with Ricky and Steven and one of them is me in a cat costume.
I remember that they were there because my ears still hurt from that high castralto of Ricky Gervais. The laugh. I've ricked your face. The laugh. That's such a good impression. He laughed. He laughed at everything. He was so good natured. He laughed at it.
He typed some coffee. Oh, by the way, ladies and gentlemen, he is the sweetest man and just a joy. All right. Those are my fast facts. That's our summary. Maybe we should... Do we need that bathroom break? Let's do a bathroom break. Let's do a bathroom break.
I could use one. By the way, I just want to say I just love these fast facts. Oh, well then if you love the fast facts, get ready for the note cards, Creed. Oh my God, I can't wait. Be still my throbbing heart. Okay. It sounded a little weird when you said it like that.
It started to be weird and then I drifted away. Okay. Go back, go to the bathroom. All right. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Every January is a time when I feel like we all reflect. You know, you can really do it any time of the year, but I think, you know, you do feel that reset.
You do. It's like you have 365 blank pages ahead of you, just waiting to be filled, and you can decide how to do that. I'm so poetic, Angela. Oh, really? Thanks. 365 blank pages. Well, I might've had some help. All right.
Well, I'm going with your book metaphor. Okay. You could think of therapy as your editorial partner, helping you to write these new chapters and create the meaningful story that you deserve to live. How do you like that? I really like it a lot. BetterHelp is fully online and making therapy affordable and convenient serving over 5 million people worldwide. It has a diverse network of more than
30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. And you can switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Write your story with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. Say hello to Tim Selects, Tim's everyday value menu. Enjoy the new spinach and Office Ladies. There's another great city that starts with a T. Tampa, Florida. Fly to Tampa on Porter Airlines to see why it's so te-rific. On your way there, relax with free beer, wine, and snacks, free fast-streaming Wi-Fi, and no middle seats. You've never flown to Florida like this before, so you'll land in Tampa ready to explore. Visit flyporter.com and actually enjoy economy.
All right, let's get into some note cards. Can we? Note cards. Yes. All right. Let's get into the episode. Let's do it. I have a note card from the cold open. Oh, what is the cold open of this episode? Okay, so the cold open is you say that Jan called
and he's like, oh, and Michael has to go in because he knows he has to fire someone. Right. And so he calls Jan and her assistant, Sherry, answers the phone. Yes. And Sherry has so much good sass. She's like, okay, well, who are you gonna fire?
And he goes, well, I'm not really sure. And she's like, we just need the name. Jan needs the name. Jan needs the name. And then he's like, who would you fire? And she's like, just give me the name. And then, and then he thinks he's hung up and he's like, I'd like to fire you. And she goes, still here. Right? He's like, I wish I could fire Sherry. Sherry. I mean, I want to know who Sherry is. Who is Sherry? Yes, I thought the same thing. So the first thing I did, I went to IMDb, Internet Movie Database. I did too.
I looked up this episode, uncredited. Uncredited. Who is Sherry? Who is Sherry? I reached out to Dave Rogers. He was the editor for this episode. You guys, he knows everything about the office. He didn't know.
That is saying something, because he is like the walking Bible of the show. He's an encyclopedic memory cat. No one knows. Listen to what Dave did. Dave reached out to Alison Jones, our casting director, who went to her storage facility. Oh my Lord.
Found the contracts for this episode, looked it up. Wow. Allison, thank you. Oh my gosh, Allison, you're like an episode of the Pelican Brief. It is. An episode. The movie. CSI The Office.
You're like CSI The Office. It is Lisa Malone. Okay. And by the way, this was shot on September 13th, 2005. Wow. Yeah. Well, Lisa, you were fantastic as Sheri. You killed it.
You killed it as Sheri. You killed it. You killed it as Sheri. Oh man, and Allison, thank you. Thank you for being our CSI, the office. I wanna go back, Angela, because I have a note that precedes your note card. Is it at five seconds?
Is it the shot of Devon and Creed at their desks? The establishing shot, yes. I noticed it too. The second shot of this episode is Creed and Devon at their desks. The establishing shot. Yes, yes. I noticed it too. The second shot of this episode is Creed and Devon at their desks. I have to imagine this was not an accident that they wanted to drive home Devon and Creed since we know that one of you.
It was well placed. Yes, yes. It's Phyllis putting on makeup and then it goes to Devon and Creed at their desks. Well, the scene with Michael and Pam, do you guys remember how he's wearing the second head? Yes. Yes.
Oh, I have a card. Pam goes in his office and he tells her that he needs to fire someone, and then he sort of implies maybe it could be her. Oh, I have two cards from this scene. And so Pam decides to quickly start flattering him. She pivots hard. About his costume and then she just gets out of the room
as quickly as possible. I could not get through that scene. Listen, Steve is funny enough on his own, but Steve with that extra Steve on his shoulder, it was too much and it wobbled in a sort of weird way. He was wobbling it on purpose. He loved it. He loved wobbling that thing. He loved it.
Anytime you give him a little cat or... That's what she said. Come on, guys. That was a great... That's what she said. Come on. He loves wobbling things. He loved wobbling that thing.
Oh, that's what she said. Hey! We got it back. We got it back. Creed, what did I write? At three minutes, 12 seconds. Oh my God, Pam is diabolical. Her turn to flattery when she realizes Michael
would fire her. Wow. Diabolical. Diabolical. I'm seeing a real devious streak in Pam. I want to just comment, if I may. Please. The brilliance of Steve Carell,
the pain and the anguish in his face when he's getting ready to fire someone. You can just see it there. He's just dying. He's absolutely dying. He's not acting. He's like, to me, he looked like a man just suffering, suffering from the pre-eminent death.
It's interesting you bring that up, Creed, because we've talked a lot about how Michael wants to be popular. He wants to be friends with people. He wants to be the life of the party. But I think this episode goes beyond that. That it isn't just that he knows that it's gonna be, he's gonna not be well liked by the person he fires. I think it really like,
I think it touches on something. He really doesn't want to hurt someone else. Yep, that's exactly right. So it's deeper than that, just unpopularity thing. I was moved by his performance in that. Yeah. Same. I mean, yeah, he crushed it. I get more pictures at Halloween of Pam as a cat and Jim as three hole punch. I think that is the most popular Halloween costume that I get sent to me. I get Angela Martin in an Argyle sweater, with a turtleneck and a headband holding a stuffed animal cat next to some guy in a mustard shirt
with a tie and his hair parted down the middle. What about you, Creed? I get the Joker. The Joker. When I walk in as the Joker. And then when Brian comes, damn it, Creed, and he hip checks you. Oh, that's a later episode. Yeah, that when you guys are both dressed in the same costume. He almost knocks you over. Oh yeah. I howl every time I see it.
That's a recurring thing. It's brilliant, brilliant. Angela, I wanna talk to you about your costume. Please. Okay, Michael comes over to accounting. You're dressed as a cat. There's three cats. Phyllis is a cat. Phyllis.
I'm a cat, you're a cat. Yes, actually we could do really quickly the rundown of costumes. Kelly is Dorothy. Phyllis, Pam and Angela are cats. Dwight is a Sith Lord. Kevin is the Dunder Mifflin superhero. Creed is a vampire.
Oscar is a lady. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if he's a character lady or just a lady. I think he's a lady. He's just a lady. Jim is three hole punch. Jim, Stanley, no costume. Ryan the temp, no costume.
And of course, Michael has the two heads. And Devin was a tramp. And Devin was a hobo. Hobo, yeah. Angela, why does your cat only have two lines for whiskers and not three? Jenna, I don't know. Why does my cat
have purple fake eyelashes? Why does your cat have weird cat ears? I mean, I just wanna say that as the resident cat lady of the office, I think you have the worst cat costume. Why do I have a fuzzy white skirt? Why? With a giant tail that was almost impossible to sit in. It was so, and the skirt didn't quite fit me
and it kept like heading south. I had to keep like grabbing it and yanking it up. It almost ruined the whole episode, that whole captain. I think now there was such a big meeting about your hair that my cat costume was just like, eh, I just put this on her. But you ended up wearing that costume like two more times. For years. And it's the worst one. It really is. I have a vague memory, a very, very vague memory of being in makeup and having them discuss how they were going to differentiate the three different cats. And it was decided that Phyllis and I would have three whiskers on each cheek and you would only have two. My cat was maimed. I feel like that happened.
I don't know if we can ask Laverne. Laverne was our makeup artist. I don't know. I don't know. But I mean, right? I just think you had... You were smaller. You didn't deserve three. They decided to give me less. I have to... While we're talking about this scene in accounting, I have to point out that we don't often, our camera guys didn't often do like a full character slow pan, you know? And they do such a hilarious one. They start at Kevin's feet and they go all the way to his head while he's filing to get him in full red leotard.
With his socks all miss bulging and brung areas. Oh my gosh. It's great. It's great. There's a great slow pan of Kevin. We should say we loved dressing up in these Halloween costumes because our outfits normally were pretty boilerplate. It was almost like we wore uniforms in a way.
And our wardrobe people loved, the wardrobe crew loved getting to dress us because it was just like gray turtleneck. Angela, give us a note card. All right, at five minutes, 23 seconds. Creed, this is a runner. This is a reference to a runner, but this is a really big deal.
What? Kelly has braided like pigtails. Oh! Her hair is down. Her hair is down. Oh hair is down her hair is down Oh my it's not in a bad member Mindy had a bun for like the whole first season and then about I guess it was like A twist a French twist. I think I mean she looked her character really changes her look and then she starts having her hair down She gets a little sassy, but this has been a big thing. We've been wondering when did they change her hair? This is the beginning. I see, I don't think this counts
because it's a Halloween costume. What? Yeah, I'm sorry to say. No, I agree. I have to say I'm with Jenna. Thank you. It doesn't count. Well, I don't know if I like you here, Kree.
All of a sudden I have someone. Oh, well. To veto. I'm sorry. Two against one. Oh, fart. Well, I got pretty excited because her hair was down. But it was a costume though. It wasn't a repudate in character thing.
See? That's what I'm saying. Am I talking to Jenna or Creed? It doesn't apply. I don't know anymore. It doesn't apply. All right. You know the scene where Pam and Jim set up a resume for Dwight to get a job someplace
else? I have a fan question about that. RCJH asked, what were you typing on the computer when you and Jim were working on Dwight's resume? I was typing what we were saying. Of course you were, Jenna. Of course you were. Because you're so method. I was very method. You're like, I am a responsible person. You would type out your lines around the computer while you were doing it?
Yeah, because Jim would say, like, I would say, what should we say here? And then he would say what we should say, and I would type it. And I see, here's the like, I would say, what should we say here? And then he would say what we should say, and I would type it. And I see, here's the thing, I'm very proud of my typing skills. Oh, we know, we know. Yeah. Creed, do we know or do we know?
We really know. You guys? Now I'm back on your side, Angela. Thank you, Creed. Just talk about, you know. Is this how it feels? Yes. This is how it feels, Angela.
We know. When you walk in this thing with your fingers, you'd be sitting there, we'd be talking about stuff in a craster and your fingers would be going like you're typing. Oh, now that is not true. It was too much. It was too much.
Tone it down. And then you would tell us about your typing speed and your level of accuracy. Well, you should know I was typing her actual lines because I could. Well, I think that's pretty great though. Because she could and I can and I will. Well, I think that's pretty great though. Because I can. Because she could and I can and I will. And you're fast too. She's very fast.
Anyway. Michael's scene with Dwight when he calls Dwight into his office and he tells Dwight that he has to fire someone and Dwight starts naming all the people he should fire. But then Michael implies maybe it should be Dwight. And then Michael's second head starts talking to Dwight. Do you remember Steve and Rain laughing during that scene? Because I do. I remember they could not get through that scene.
I'm sitting out at reception in the background and they were cracking themselves up in there. Rain was literally doubling over because he was like kind of leaning forward and he would just kind of collapse into himself. He was laughing so hard. There must be deleted scenes of that scene. Oh man, I would love to see those.
I would love to see that. That is a funny scene. Well, Paul Feig called in when we did Office Olympics and he said one of the things he loved about directing episodes of our shows is that you could really find a shot that was cool and you would have the support of Greg to just kind of go with it. And he sort of found that shot where Dwight as
the Sith Lord has his hood kind of like, it looks like it's straight out of the movie. It does. You know? Yes. And they just loved that. They shot from the side, right? Yeah, shot from the side. And they sort of just found that and went with it. And Greg was totally supportive of it. And Paul was talking about like how fun that was to have
that creative freedom and find those little nuggets. And it's so cool looking. We had a lot of shots like that. They're just more the cookie cutter or a stereotype, you know, sitcom stuff. And we get interesting shots. Yeah. Because the cameramen were so great. And something that we haven't talked about on the show yet is the idea of actor marks. So usually on a television show, so that they can get these shots,
they put a little piece of tape on the ground. And if you, for example, if Jim had to walk up to Pam's desk, there would be a little mark on the ground and he would have to stand exactly on that mark. And it's really hard to do. I mean, do you guys find it hard to do? I'm always, I feel like I'm always looking down for the tape and then I get to my spot
and I look up. It's like a hard thing to manage. Well, on our show, we did not have that. They would just let us wander. They would say, just walk up in this general area and the camera will find you. It was so loosey goosey, so amazing. Didn't you say you were in a band called Lucy Goosey? I was in a band called Lucy Goosey. What? I was in a band with Peter White, who used to play with Al Stewart,
and he probably still does. We had a band with Dave Camp on sax, and I remember we played the rap party for this movie I did with, worked on with Bo Bridges at the beach house, at Lloyd Bridges' house, Lucy Goosey. We played out there and they were dancing out there like Annette Funicello in the surf and stuff. Oh my gosh.
Lucy Goosey. Creed, we just need you to sit here and tell us about all your stories. Creed, you have literally the most interesting life. I have a fan question for you. I'm a fascinating character. You are. And humble too. This is a fan question from Todd Myers and this feels like a good place to ask it. Who is the biggest rock star you ever partied with during your touring days?
Oh. Wow. Partied with? It maybe doesn't have to be the biggest. It could just, what's the most interesting? Yeah. I lived for a while at the Camrose Highland Estates, and Linda Ronstadt was there, Laura Nero was there,
Jackson Brown used to, there was a lot of people playing at this place and lived there and they would play their instruments. You hear the instruments going around the Cameroon Highland Estates, and Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers was there and one night Butch came over. Wait, wait, wait, I'm so sorry. You all lived together?
No, we lived at the States in little bungalows. You could rent these bungalows at the Cameros Highland States. Now it's been fixed up a little bit. It's right next to the Veterans of War and War place, I think, right on Highland Boulevard, right on Highland Boulevard. Right off to get off the freeways, right there. And like a lot of artists live there.
A lot of artists were living there. So Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers came over one night, and Griffin from The Bread, and Jesse Ed Davis, who used to play with John Lennon, came over one night and we jammed, we jammed for hours and hours and hours and hours. And there was a lot of heavyweight guitar players there that night.
And remember Butch wanted me to go back to Alabama and be the lead singer for this group, Cowboy. But that never happened. Creed, your life is amazing. Jenna, I don't know that we would have been hip enough to hang out there. We would not. Well, I have a card right here.
Tell me. Seven minutes, 44 seconds. Creed, we have some PPC rivalry. Oh, I've got it down. Pam versus Angela. Angela Sass? Angela Sass, but also same category. Same category.
What? I get this. So my character says, what, you brought brownies? Like, what did you bring? And you're like, I brought brownies. Brownies. And like, but I brought cookies. Same category. Yeah.
Same category. You should have brought something savory. You know, Angela had a way. Is that what you say in the thing? Same category? I say same category. I remember that. Well, I mean, I feel like there's a backstory missing here. Did you assign me something other than brownies? I'm sure I did. That's your implication. Yes.
You're implying that I went rogue and brought brownies instead of chips and dip. I clearly at some party planning- Don't you say where's the chips and dip or something? Yes. I clearly at some party planning committee meeting said, all right, I will make sugar cookies. Why don't you bring the dip and chips and then you show up with these fricking brownies. How dare you? Wait, Sam, can we see that? Those aren't chips and dip. No, I made brownies.
What? I'm just trying to figure out why you're sabotaging things. I made brownies. And I made cookies. Same category. All right, after watching that clip, I will admit I think Pam did go a little rogue. Clearly you assigned me chips and dip. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you. Same category.
Yeah. Same category. All right. I needed to hear that because I think, Jenna, if it was your house and you were having a party, you would be like, hey, come on. Yeah. All right. Guys, I think we should go to a break,
and then we'll come back and finish the episode. All right. Creed, how are you doing? I'm doing wonderful. Oh my god, I love having you here, Creed. I do too. I do too. And we are back with my delightful neighbor
and an office favorite, Creed Brown. Thank you. Creed, we're gonna make you come back on this podcast all the time. I hope you're ready. Yeah. You know what? We could carpool. We could.
I could swing by and pick you up. You're like, oh my God, Angela, lurking, lurking these office ladies. You guys, do you remember the scene where Jim takes a phone call from a potential employer for Dwight and he does a Michael Scott impression. It's really good. John does a very good job. It's at eight minutes, 34 seconds. Oh, you've got the time code.
Guys, is this when we find out that Michael's middle name is Gary? Oh, is this the first time it's said? Because he says Michael G Scott, Michael Gary Scott. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. Because later it was when we had the scene
where we showed him as a little boy and he doesn't get all the love that he wanted because he wanted a family. That's later, right? Yeah, yeah. Okay, that was Gary. We knew Gary there. That might be, that might be the first time.
I don't know. I'm putting it out there. Our fans will know. Our fans will let us know first time. I don't know. I'm putting it out there. Our fans will know. Our fans will let us know for sure. I loved the scene. I just thought that John crushed it as Michael Scott. And it also had the Jim and Pam air high five. The first air high five.
Yes. I'm getting creeds getting misty eyed. I got, I literally, when I saw it, I think I audibly said out loud to no one, aw. Yeah, super cute. Okay, so I have a question about the air high five. Say it. So I was trying to do the air high five
with my daughter, Isabelle, now granted. She's 11, I'm 48, maybe our timing's off. We couldn't get it our timing's off. We couldn't get it. It's difficult. You guys did it perfectly. Yeah. And you know what?
We kind of did it perfectly the first time. It was meant to be. It was meant to be. That speaks to our chemistry, I believe. So shortly after this momentous air high five, very sadly, Pam tells Jim he should go for the job at Cumberland Mills. But the job is in Maryland and he is so hurt. This happens a lot with you guys.
Yeah. Him going off to do a job, a recurring theme, right? It is because he's, you know, later he's gonna go off to the other branch. And then later to New York and do that stuff with the sports thing, right? Yeah. It kept happening.
And then you go to art camp or school or... Art camp? I went to a university. Thank you very much. Art camp. Plaster of Paris making place. Geez. But yes, they constantly are being pushed together and pulled apart, right? Yeah, they are. Always, yeah. It's true. But sometimes just through a comment, we're seeing in this second season, in each episode, there seems to be a really
sweet moment with Jim and Pam and then a moment where someone gets their feelings hurt a little bit. So many feelings. So many feelings. Feelings. But then at the end, Jim admits that if it weren't for Pam, he would take the job at Cumberland Mills because the pay is twice as much, it's a better job, yada, yada. So why is he staying? He just basically admitted why he stays at this job.
Yes. Yeah. What was the one where he admitted that crabs are his favorite food, so he was going to go to this Maryland. Was that Maryland? But that was it. Yeah. It was the crab. That was the crab thing. Yeah. Soft-shelled crabs are apparently one of his favorites.
Yes, exactly. Who knew? Well, he eats that tuna sandwich every day for lunch. So he is a seafood fan. So he just stinks all the time. I guess so. Jim kind of stinks. Andy could have called him crab if he wanted to.
Oh, crabby. Jim eats tuna sandwiches and Pam eats sour cream and onion chips. They're a match made. And I eat mung beans, apparently. Wow, what is there? The smells in this all day. They're a match made. And I eat mung beans apparently. Wow, what is there, the smells in this all. Smells and melts.
I know, yeah. Oh dear. All right, so finally Michael asks for Jim's help and he wants to do some role playing where he tries to fire someone and that is just a delicious scene. Did you enjoy that one? How did John get through it is what I wanna know.
When like Steve is Michael is like, what are you doing? I'm gonna kill myself. And he's like, wait, is this you as you or who are you right now? What is happening? John has to check in. And this brings us to your big scene.
Your big scene. Oh, here we are. This is it. After that scene, he calls you in and tell us, break it down for us, what was it like to sit in that chair and now you're gonna launch into Five Pages with Steve Carell? Right. I mean, I had never had Five Pages with Steve Carell, or Six and a Half, you said. Six and a Half. Six and a Half, originally. They may have cut it down, but it took a long, like hours to get through that thing. Yeah. And I mean, I never had more than a few lines with him one-on-one.
So yeah, let's hear about it. Well, first of all, there was a scene where I slowly take out the teeth, you know, and I resolve myself. I gird my loins, as it were. I stand up within a resolute and I march in like a Nesferatu, you know, with a purpose. Are these some of your notes that you wrote in your script for intention? No, no. This is just him storytelling, Jenna. It's the B story. It's the storytelling.
I'm into the story right now. Yes, go. Exactly. So you march in. So I march in and then I remember I sit back like this and I cross my feet and I kind of houched down and I have my arms crossed because I'm protecting myself from attack like this. And he goes, well, I'll Creed, I just don't like this. I said, well, you want to leave?
He says, no, no, I don't. No, and yes, you do. No, no, I don't. You're the hardest person to fire ever. You want to leave? No, no, really, no, I know I'm very happy here. I said, Creed, I've got to fire somebody and it's got to be, well, then fire Devin.
He's horrible and he's a job. I'm so much better at my job, and I'm doing the Creed voice right now too. He goes up a bitch, you know? And then I just fought, I just fought for my survival. And we kept doing it over and over and over, and finally, and Steve is so great. It's like, you all have done scenes with people
where it's forcing it, it's so hard to get through a scene. Working with Steven was like, he kept tossing me these big beach balls and I had a Nerf bat, which is easy. It was easy to hit those things, you know? God bless him. He's a very giving, giving person, you know? And when you're in scenes with him,
he's so eager for you to get the laugh. He doesn't, some actors, guys out there, they want to get a laugh. They want that moment. And Steve is so eager for you to get the laugh. He doesn't, some actors, guys out there, they want to get the laugh. They want that moment. And Steve is so eager to share it and really just what makes the scene work is what he focuses on. But Dave Rogers later, he said,
what made him laugh the most is when I stood up and he said, no, no, you're doing a good job. Good for you. That, that, that, that, that, that. I played. I love that. I played in my finger and all that stuff was just off the top of my head.
Yeah. When I rewatched it, I was like, oh, that is Creed. That is classic. That is just Creed being Creed. Yeah. Yeah. That is actually, yeah. Cause I feel like you've left me voicemails where you're like, hey, pumpkin, da, da, da,
da, da, da. I was just stuttering perhaps too. But you were doing a bit. I was doing a bit, yeah. No. But still I look at that with fond memories. It was a stuttering perhaps too. You were doing a bit. I was doing a bit, yeah. No, but still I look at that with fond memories. It was a great, and I thank Steve so much for being so gracious as an actor to work with. So after that scene, Michael does fire Devin in a much shorter scene.
Devin gets so angry. He announces to the office, if anyone wants to join me at Poor Richard's Bar, Poor Richard's Bar, is this the first mention of Poor Richard's Bar? Well, he says he gives him a chili. He gives him a, she says- Michael gives him a chili coupon. Chili coupon, yeah. Which is a nice nod back to the Dundies. Yeah, yeah.
He rips it up. He rips it up, yeah. But have we, because we end up mentioning Poor Richard's Bar over and over again, and we go there eventually, but have we mentioned it yet? Oh, in the basketball episode. I think Darrell suggests that we all get drinks at Poor Richards. Okay, in that scene though,
where Devin invites everyone to Poor Richards, there's three people he does not invite. Oh, yeah, you're right. He lists a bunch of names. Who does he not? It's very personal. It's personal. Who are they? He does not invite Michael. Of course. He does not bunch of names. Who does he know? It's very personal. It's personal. Who are they? He does not invite Michael.
Of course. He does not invite Dwight. He does not invite Angela. He doesn't invite you? No. Why? They're just made... It's arbitrary.
It's an arbitrary... Why not you? I'm sure I've been bitchy to him at some point. I'm sure. Or maybe he just knew you wouldn't go. Maybe so. He might have had a crush on you too. Oh, come on.
Oh, he might have, you never know. So he leaves and he smashes a pumpkin. There we go. Pumpkin, pumpkin. And when we go downstairs, we see Hank, the security guy, at the security desk who was played by Hugh Dane. God rest his peace. Yes, who passed away a couple of years ago.
He was so nice. Yeah. Just a sweetheart. And so great as Hank. His delivery was always perfect. Amazing. Is this the first time we see Hank at the security desk? I think so.
It has to be. You guys leave to go to the dojo. Yeah. But I don't think we saw him there. You don't see him, no. Well, it's brilliant because there he is, and he's sitting there, and it's another example of introducing a character in an episode where they don't speak, but they will eventually.
Yeah. They will come back. He did that with so many people. He did that with Craig in the warehouse in the Alliance. You just see him in the background watching Dwight pop out of the box. Creed, of course, you were in the warehouse in the Alliance. You just see him in the background watching Dwight pop out of the box. Creed, of course, you were in the background forever.
And then now Hugh Dane in the background is the security officer. Just so thoughtful. And this thing that I love about our show and we've talked about Creed is that Greg had the audience just start in the middle. He doesn't explain things to you. You discover it as you go.
It's not spoon fed information. Yes. I love that. Well, I don't think we can end this episode without talking about Michael's list of former costumes. Oh, please list them. Okay. He's really, really bummed the camera crew wasn't there the Halloween before when he was Janet Jackson's boob. Very topical. He's really bummed you guys missed it when he was Janet Jackson's boob, very topical. He's really bummed you guys missed it when he was Monica Lewinsky's dress. Twice. Yeah, twice.
And then he was Monica Lewinsky the year before. And then before that he was OJ Simpson. So very topical, great costumes that he was really sad the camera crew missed. I know you're gonna wanna talk about the very end with Michael and the trick-or-treaters because it's just such a touching moment. All right, I cried.
Every time I watch it. I did too, I did too. Every time. I was loving the show and then when it got to that episode, it just killed me. I said, oh my God, this is a perfect episode. It's one of the great ones, you know? Yes, at the end of the episode, Michael goes home
and you see him sitting alone, very lonely, on the couch. And then the doorbell rings and there are trick-or-treaters at the door. And there was a big debate on set about how exactly this scene should play out, about whether or not the kids should be nice to Michael or if they should be annoyed by Michael, how Michael should be with the kids, should he be off-putting, should he be kind. And the writers and producers also, well, they also discussed if he should be happy or sad while handing out the candy. And they decided that they were going to start on that spy shot of Michael looking sad and lonely, all alone on Halloween night.
But when he gets to the door, I'm going to cry saying it, he lights up, he makes his silly jokes, the kids laugh. The kids love him. Love him. They love him. And it ends on him making a connection. I just think it is the most kind and heartbreaking, wonderful scene. I think it's moments like this that make The Office so special.
We just spend an entire episode kind of laughing at Michael Scott or finding him annoying, but then in the end, he just breaks your heart with his vulnerability. Take them all. Don't they drop them? Don't worry. Take them all. Take them all. Take them all.
Take them all. Take them all. And they love him. All yours, yeah. That's the first time we saw him just so loving. Really? Don't you think so? At that moment, we saw his heart.
We saw his heart come out there at that moment. Yeah. Well, and you... Tore me up. Now, tore me up, and you have to think that Michael is somewhere being a great dad. Yeah. He's a great dad. And I wish we could see that. That's the one thing when we talk about a reunion, obviously, you know, we don't want to tread on hallowed ground that is the office, and we don't want to mess with anything that everyone loves so much.
But boy, I would love to see where some of these people are and I would love to see Michael as a dad. Yes, yes. Do you agree that when you watch that scene, I think more than any other scene I can recall, I see Steve. Yes. That is Steve handing out candy.
Absolutely, yes. That's the kind of just kindhearted gentleman that he is. Sweet man. And I think that's part of the reason too, why it hits you that hard, Jenna, because we see our friend and we see the kind person he is that gets to shine through, which often as Michael Scott does not.
No, he does not. That's true. Well, I have one little final piece of trivia. All right. In the credits at the end as it rolls, over the Dedal-D logo, which Dedal-D is Greg's company, his daughter Haley actually drew the picture that says Dedal-D when she was little.
You hear, and it's the only time it ever happens, Dwight's voice say, quiet you. Oh, Angela. Really? But do we know why that happened? I think they loved it. They pulled it from earlier in the episode when Dwight is the Sith Lord. Is that the only time that they-
It's the only time there's dialogue over Dedal-D. Wow. Oh, I'm kind of moved by that. That's kind of cool, right? Yeah. Quiet you. Quiet you. Quiet you. Well, we did it, guys.
We did it. We did it. That was the Halloween episode creed. Thank you. Thank you so much for coming. But before you go, will you tell us what are you up to now? What are you doing?
You have an album and you're touring. I'm touring. I was in Europe, UK, and in Scandinavia for a month, touring and doing shows. in Europe, UK and Scandinavia for a month touring and doing shows, had like seven, I'm bragging now, seven sold out shows to the UK. Went great, I'm off to Australia, New Zealand in February. And then you did the whole East Coast too because I was texting with you and you were like, yeah.
Then I did the East Coast, had a great tour there too. And the fans, and I want to thank all the Office fans for coming out and supporting my character and my music and it truly means a lot. I'm having my second childhood now doing this. And by the way, I have a surprise for you ladies. What is it? I brought, which I think may be the single, if there's going to be a single from my... I'm going to play you a little snippet if you'd like. Yes, please.
Of the album. Can we do this in there? Can I play it right now for you? And you guys, before he plays the song, I just wanna encourage you, if Creed is coming to a town near you, go see his show. It is fantastic. And apparently he also makes fun of me during it. Quite a bit, Angela, yes. And we are trying to figure out one of your locations where I can come on stage and give it to you right back.
Oh, we... Where can people find the schedule? Creedbratton stage and give it to you right back. Where can people find the schedule? Creedbratton.com. We love you Creed. All right, let's hear it. All right, here we go. And the ride. You taught me how, you taught me then How I could one day be your friend Just don't lie Don't control it by and by We'll be side by side
We'll be side by side Forward, center, right All right, that's that song. There it is gang. What do you think? Well, Angela's sobbing. I just started crying. The song is so beautiful Creed, but also, and I totally am emotional, but oh my God, it might be too emotional. Well, you know what? Do you ever have just like a wave hit you where you're like, you know you're in a special moment? Yeah. And it just hit me. Well, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like, I'm like and I'm facing my best friend who is now my boss lady business partner and I'm so proud of us and this journey we've taken together and then I just love you Creed. Oh I love you sweetie. You're like you know family family. Well I've I've ladies and gentlemen when
I the last album I did I had a song called More Than You Know and I one of the first people I ever played it for was for you and Josh you you know, at your house. I came over and acoustically played it, you know, and she started crying. I knew I had a winner then. Well, Creed, some of my favorite memories on the set were at lunchtime when you would play guitar and Ed would play banjo. Ed's trailer was next to mine. You'd go in his trailer and the two of you would play through my lunch. And you guys would to mine. You'd go in his trailer and the two of you would play through my lunch. And I just loved it.
And you guys would come over and stick your hand in and listen. We'd come over and hang out. For years, my alarm clock is banjo music because it would make me think of you guys. And sometimes, especially when I was pregnant, if we had a little break, I might take a cat nap and I'd wake up to banjo music. And it was like so pleasing that I made my alarm clock banjo. Cause I thought,
oh, maybe I won't wake up grumpy. Ed and I had so much fun. He's a, he's a great banjo player. I haven't played with him in a long time because he, we work in all the time, but I would love to. Oh yeah. You guys were great together. Well, thank you again. Thank you so much for having me. My dear friends. Creed, can we end with a final fan question? Yes, of course. This is from Tim Blair. Tim asked, do you have a favorite Creed line
from the whole show? Which one's Pam? Ah! Ah! Which question, Pam? Yes. I could say, gosh, I don't know. It probably would be someone making soup or which one's Pam.
But I think actually I would have to be... In the 60s, I made love to many, many women, often outdoors in the rain and the mud. It's possible a man slipped in. There'd be no way of knowing. Yes. Yes. Applause from the booth. And that is how you end an episode, my friend.
Thank you, Fred and Bee. Thank you, Creed. Oh, everyone, please join us next week when we will be talking about the fight. The fight. Yeah. We'll miss you, Creed. You have to come back. Oh, I'd love to come back.
Okay. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva.
Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.